Are complaining.
We are making excuses and we do it
everyday because it feels a lot better
to shit on somebody else.
Then look at yourself and shit on
yourself.
[inaudible]
whether it's one man,
I don't look at anybody else.
I have no fucking idea what you guys are
up to and I shit on myself every day.
I critique everything I do.
Everything is my fault.
Period.
End of story.
I can sit and dwell on all the things.
Somebody hits me with a fucking car
tomorrow.
I'm like,
fuck,
I shouldn't have left the house that
early.
You get into that fucking mindset.
I promise you shit changes.
You need to fucking suffocate your
bullshit.
You're at this conference.
That means you need to suffocate your
bullshit period.
Either need to figure out who's holding
you back and their judgment and go to
them.
I want you to get out of this fucking
conference.
Go to your car or call your mom and say
fuck you.
She's
the person that is suppressing you
because she's miserable and misery loves
company.
I'm being dead serious with you.
I understand it's not a popular thing to
say.
I understand,
but there's only a couple of things that
I'm seeing in the world today,
which is people aren't doing things
because they're fearful of other
people's judgments,
which usually comes from parenting or
environment or circumstance,
and they're still keeping negative
energy around them because they're
obligated and I get it.
I have negative people in my life too
that I keep around as well,
but to let that dictate your only life
is fucking ludicrous and all I know.
How about,
let me actually,
you know what?
I'm going to give you a real weird one.
I want every person to do me a huge
favor.
If you really want to know what's
running through my fucking body,
go volunteer at a nursing home for one
day.
Go volunteer at a nursing home for one
Number one,
it's just a nice thing to do and you'll
probably feel pretty awesome about it.
Number two,
don't talk to eight people.
Six,
four,
you're going to see something that is
going to scare the living shit out of
here.
It's called regret.
Regret,
scares the shit out of me.
Regret is the fuel besides gratitude
that drives my life.
You will see people and they will tell
you things about the things they didn't
do and the silliness to why they didn't
do it and they're running out of time.
You sit in this room and you have time.
You have time.
If you're 70 80 90 of time,
if you're 15 you've time,
but to sit and list all the reasons you
can't.
It's just,
here's how I look at it.
If anybody that looks like you has ever
done it,
then you can too.
If you know,
if some kid that grew up with two
alcoholic parents,
right and grew up in an orphanage made
it,
you can too.
It's not necessarily that I don't
believe in luck or circumstance.
I believe in all of that.
I really,
I understand that this is not about
that.
It's about mindset.
The second you start having losing
mindset,
you've already fucking lost.
I love when people think shit like the
secret is real fucking real.
Here's how it works.
Friends.
If you actually are optimistic and you
make a goal and your actions map to it,
you've miraculously get somewhere close
to it.
Sitting on your couch,
jerking off and saying,
I wish I had $1 million.
The amount of people talking big game in
this office,
in this room office,
clearly I use that a lot.
The amount of people talking big game at
this conference right now where their
ambitions don't match their actions.
I mean people rolling around here and
say they're going to make 100 million a
year and then take the whole weekend
off.
Then I have nothing going for themselves
yet.
Do you know quiet my head is,
do you know how quiet my head is?
My head is soup.
It is super quiet in here.
You know why no voices allowed.
No voices allowed.
Not My wife's,
not my kids,
not my business partners,
not my parents.
Nobody.
I'm in it for me in my own mind.
The reason I can give so much to
everybody else,
it's because I'm good because I made it
with myself.
Period.
End of story
and I've been talking about a lot of
things and the reason I'm going further
down this rabbit hole of tuned out
everybody else is as I've gotten to know
people like,
oh,
they're scared because their partner
makes fun of them all the time.
Like it's just,
it's just very basic behavior,
right?
It's very basic behavior and so I just
don't want that for you anymore.
Like has anybody realize guys,
it's 400 trillion to one.
The odds of being in this fucking room
right now is 400 trillion to one.
The fact that your mom and dad had sex
at that exact second to create you is
fucking insane and we are wasting it
away and I just don't want you to do
that mainly because I get a high off of
the email that you send me in six years
about this suffocating conversation.
Okay?
Content and distribution.
You have to make stuff.
Figure out what kind of content producer
you are.
Are you good at writing?
Are you good at talking?
Are you good in front of video?
Everybody thinks,
oh,
videos.
The answer,
not the answer.
If you suck on video,
can you talk?
Can you write?
Are you charismatic in front of a
camera?
All three are trying to video and
written word audio.
They play forever.
Figuring out which one you're good at
and go deep into that.
Everybody's trying to make you fix all
your shortcomings.
Fuck your shortcomings,
triple down on your strengths and is
your biggest advantage.
Please leave
this conference.
Figure out first you want to sell.
Actually,
before I figure out what you want your
life to be.
Do you really want all that money?
Do you really want to let them?
What do you want?
Figured that out.
Then figure out what you want to sell
your time,
your service,
a product.
I don't care.
A festival.
I figure out something you believe in
that you sell and then finally,
number three,
figured out how to let the world know
about it at the lowest possible cost.
Today,
if it's under 30 year olds,
that's instagram influencers and
snapchat ads.
They're $3 CPMS.
Everybody writes off snapchat because
instagram copies all its features.
That's exactly when I went all in on
snapchat the last three months and I'm
buying awareness at a price I've never
seen before.
If the person is under 30
okay,
be a practitioner.
I get a lot of accolades.
Yeah.
Gary,
I,
why do you think I do all this content
so I do it?
Yeah.
I built my personal brand,
not necessarily for the brand halo
effect to keep me in check to always be
on top of shit.
I'm in the green right now.
Tweeting and texting and consuming and
creating content.
I'm putting in work every day work and I
know the nuances of a filter and a geo
location and the copy of a facebook
post,
like everybody's talking about this
stuff doesn't work.
No,
no,
you don't work
you the ambition.
If you,
if you fucking came to this conference,
you clearly want something.
So if that's the case,
how do you not have 30 hours to go do
research on how to do this shit?
For Real.
I'll give you a free resource on how to
post ads on facebook,
how to find influencers on Instagram,
how to do snapchat better,
how to do linkedin better.
They'll give you free reshot resource
right now.
Here it is.
want something?
Go fucking get it.
It's called search engine.
How do I post better on instagram and
turn?
My friends are being serious.
I know it's funny but I'm flabbergasted
by people hitting me up.
Gary,
how do I get it?
You know I want to apply for it.
I saw you meant literally the scene.
The snap on the way.
This is Gary saw your hiring content
creators.
I do that.
I'm like,
are you fucking kidding me?
Calm asshole.
And you apply and be like,
why do we need,
you have the self start.
You have to self start.
If you believe like I do that mobile
devices have the consumer's attention
and that facebook,
instagram,
snapchat,
youtube,
podcasts have the percentage of time.
By the way,
this is not a debate.
This is data.
They own it besides games and utility.
It's social networks.
You may not like it.
You may not like the teenage girl duck
faces 24 hours a day.
It doesn't matter because I've got news
for you.
You're 40 year old sister's duck facing
too.
It's 2017
okay.
What do you think is coming next?
Are you ready for augmented reality?
Are you ready for machine learning,
for Ai,
for messengers,
for Vr?
I mean,
look,
how many people here are retiring within
the next 10 years and I don't mean
you're going to crush it and buy a
fucking island.
I mean,
you're old and you're fucking finished.
Great.
[inaudible] your hand if you're retiring
in 10 years.
Understood.
Okay.
For the 21 of you,
you can take some of this with some
level of grain of salt,
but for the rest of you,
everything,
I believe in everything that is
converting and creating your business
opportunities in today's world did not
exist 12 years ago.
All of it.
Not facebook,
not smartphones,
not youtube,
not snapchat,
none of it.
What do you think happens next?
Can you imagine if I told you 10 years
ago that you would prefer your teenage
girl to take a drive with a stranger
than drive herself?
Would you believe that we're living
through massive social norm changes?
Number,
how weird it was to online date,
not so much anymore.
We don't live in through massive human
shifts.
This is the biggest culture shift since
the printing press.
The Internet is only roughly 20 years
old in being a consumer product for all
of us.
This is just starting and the level of
disrespect or the level of,
it's kind of something the unbelievable
nature of you not becoming ridiculously
educated in this shit blows my mind.
You can not have the audacity for
ambition in the future world without
putting in hundreds of hours of homework
to the nuances of had a creek
communications and distributed them on
this device.
Your ass.
If you don't do it and I don't want
outsourcing to nieces and I don't want
fucking bullshit excuses and I don't
want to hear that you're not good on
camera then fucking right rick,
I don't care.
But you need to fucking make a decision
today.
Are you going to allow yourself to buy
bullshit programs for the rest of your
life and come to shit like this or are
you going to finally fucking eat shit
and do something about it?
Are you,
are you
going to fuck him for 10 or are you
going to make pretend you're a business
person cause it feels nice.
Or are you going to become a business
person paying your big to look?
The part is a great business for other
people.
Eating shit for a decade and doing it
for yourself is a good one for you in
that eating shit decade.
If you actually get smart and stop
fucking judging every new thing that
comes along.
And you know what's so funny to me?
What's the funny of me is people that
get fancy,
let me on this fancy like the shit out
of it.
The amount of people that aren't where
they want to be.
Okay.
And did say,
well,
I don't have time for facebook.
I don't have time to learn another APP
like snapchat yet.
You're not winning.
Yeah,
I don't get them a man.
I don't understand.
You're not where you're at.
You'd rather spend thousands of dollars
on dumb shit to somebody teaching you
some fucking secret that doesn't exist.
Then you spending the 40 hours to learn
the newest thing even if it dies.
Let me tell you the story about Social
Cam.
Social camp came out six years ago.
I spent a fucking 50 60 a hundred hours
on it,
figuring it out,
right?
That's what I did and worked for about
four months and then the whole thing
collapsed and nobody gave a fuck about
social camp wastes of time or in those
learnings on a mobile first video
platform.
Did I learn what made me bet unbind
number two,
I bet on vine vine comes out.
Everybody's like,
who gives a fuck?
Six seconds videos stupid.
I'm like,
not me.
I'm going to learn everything about
this.
I'm going to be friends with everybody.
What happens with fine.
That's pretty good.
I get a,
I started an agency representing a bunch
of talent with Jerome Jarre.
We make a couple of bucks but I learned,
I learned alert.
What happens with vine dies,
but what happens next?
Instagram video and what happens in the
last year for me on instagram video,
the last four years of me learning
mobile first video dynamics on two
things I wasted my time on.
Even though I had hundreds of millions
of dollars,
I wasn't too fucking fancy to put in the
work at two o'clock in the morning cause
I'm fucking hungry and I back at the
fuck up.
Then instagram comics,
then instagram comes and then I hit pay
dirt six years in the making a whole lot
of losing along the way,
but learning my craft,
learning my craft.
I end with this.
My friends in Utah,
do you actually know what the fuck
you're doing?
Are you actually putting in the work?
Do you really want this that bad or do
you want to make it look like you want
it that bad?
I challenge you and I hope to see you
soon.
Thank you.